let's talk about jobs and unemployment a
little bit today there are lies there's
ignorant there's bad faith argumentation
and then there's combining all three to
weaponize them against your political
opponents when you know that your
followers will believe any dumb thing
that you tell them and Donald Trump is
now claiming that his his daughter
Ivanka this is so insane who has no
formal role with the administration has
single-handedly created 15 million jobs
herself now question one is she has no
role with the administration how exactly
is she creating jobs
never mind 15 million jobs let's table
that question for now so that we avoid
crying let's go to the video right away
and then I will discuss it don't Ivanka
Trump who just wants to have people
working that's what I gave her lots of
options and what do you like and she
created over 15 million jobs working
with some of you but working with the
the biggest companies in the world they
were training and training like nobody
has ever seen but she started off with a
goal of 500,000 jobs and that she's up
to over 15 million so there are tons of
Trumpets who will see this video and
they're going to believe it now let's
just do the math on it the US population
is estimated right now to be 331 million
let's call it 330 million people a rough
estimate of the number of people working
in the u.s. in 2020
prior to the virus remember since the
virus has started more than 16 million
people have filed for unemployment an
even bigger number have lost their jobs
but before the virus we had a hundred
and fifty eight million people working
in the u.s. Trump says Ivanka created 15
million jobs if Ivanka created 15
million jobs that is 10 percent of all
the jobs in the United States can you
imagine a more obviously false assertion
than the idea that Trump's daughter who
has no official position in the White
House
and has essentially done nothing created
ten percent of the jobs in the United
States but let's take it a step further
even if you ignore that obviously ten
percent of American jobs couldn't
possibly have been created by Ivanka
Trump the entire American economy
prior to coronavirus had added only six
point six point two million jobs period
so Donald Trump is arguing that his
daughter created 8 million jobs above
and beyond all jobs that are known to
have been created during the Trump
administration now you might hear this
and say obviously nobody's going to
believe that and you would be very very
wrong search Twitter search the trumpet
on claves of the Internet and you will
realize that this has already become a
talking point that people are using to
prop up Ivanka why so many Trump is
they're desperate to prop up Ivanka
right now I really couldn't tell you it
is a talking point that they are using
relentlessly apparently applying zero
critical thinking skills to the claim or
maybe some of them are realizing that
it's a lie but repeating the lie anyway
it genuinely seems that Donald Trump
doesn't understand numbers just simple
numbers or he's just lying and when it
comes to Trump's relationship with
Ivanka you know I I hope this is not off
caller off-color to mention but Trump's
the same guy who has previously called
his daughter voluptuous Trump's the same
guy who has previously said his daughter
is someone that he would love to be
dating if she wasn't his daughter so
maybe there's more here maybe it's just
Trump says really strange things about
Ivanka in general and they could be
economic or they could be about other
things but this is such an obvious lie
and it's particularly sinister now when
we have lost sixteen point eight million
jobs minimum the real number is higher
because not everybody's filed for
unemployment who has lost their job
we have lost more than 16 million jobs
in three weeks due to the virus and
Trump is sitting around bragging
about his daughter supposedly creating
10% of all jobs in the American economy
incredible and people are falling for it